Daniel: All right.
The next presentation is with Pablo
Fernandez-Maquieira.
So welcome back, Pablo.
Pablo: Hello here.
Daniel: Okay, I did take us on an
adventure of curiosity.
Pablo: Yes.
I'm going to start sharing my screen.
Let me know if everything is all right.
Daniel: Should be perfect.
Pablo: Yes.
Cool.
So this is one of my favorite memes and
probably most of you know it.
This reference is the cave of Platon and
to me it was kind of fine treated truth
that now with active inference seems like
we are closer to demonstrate.
That how it is.
So the first time that I start act and
surf at the Institute, this was kind of
my feeling or my face was looking into
something that it was complex, scary and
look interesting.
So I went why I decided to go through it.
.
I envision a world where people is
driving by stronger incentives that
motivate them to reduce uncertainty in
the systems they are part of.
My approach is through games which are
going to go later.
But I really on this talk, want to
encourage all kinds of persons or people
that are curious.
And I want them to act and get involved
in the community.
Because you may find that for now most of
the actors are scientists and very well
on reputed people.
And you might think that you are not a
part of it, but very far away from that.
The Institute.
Encourage the opposite.
So I'm super glad to have been through
this journey and I wanted to share a
little bit of my background and then we
go to the game.
Here is the second and last meme.
The world you were raised to survive is
no longer exist.
We are on digital revolution and with
this digital revolution it comes a bunch
of different things that are evolving and
hopefully bring us to a better world.
Okay, who I am?
I'm Pablo.
My name is Pablo.
But more defined or what best define me
is my action and my experiences.
I think role gameplays and sports movies
are super important and as a kid I was
dyslexic and the system didn't fill my
necessities.
So I really hated school.
But I love learning and it's something
that I've been doing all my life.
And it's curious how a system that is
designed to give you knowledge and to
help you with the learning, in my case it
didn't work at all.
That's a little starting point.
I believe in the copy transformation and
combine of things and on my adulthood
everything shifted and I became
successful, professional and I love it.
Teams.
What I do for a living is product manager
and what I do on my pet projects site
projects, call it as you want is related
to gaming and gamifying organizations and
experiences.
Nowadays I trust more my intuition which
is something that it really was broken
during my childhood and you will see a
little bit more about that.
Here are some things of my interest.
Licenses like open science which is the
case of the Institute philosophy that's
the first meme education, governance,
family, art, love, communication,
technology and nature and a bunch of
other things that I will be happy to
share any other time.
One of the questions that Daniel asked me
for this talk is what was exciting for me
about all this, what right?
And for me, when I give talks, I like to
share a view of the last hundred years
and the Industrial revolution and how the
ones that were on this world before us
did something right.
I'm sure that we all know big mistakes or
big things that have failed or that could
be better through iterations.
But on data it's very promising and very
good.
I think it's inspiring to have the basic
education, how it grows, the vaccination,
what it did for us, democracy and how
poverty dropped draxily, how literacy it
grew and because all these things, child
mortality just went very low.
So basically the future of education is
what makes me be excited.
How I ended up on this ecosystem.
It's super random and I'm going to
explain it in hopefully two to five
minutes.
I as a product manager and very
interested on technology.
I heard about Blockchains back in 2015
and I didn't understood anything at all.
And then back in 2017 I heard about a I
didn't start them, did not play that game.
.
But it was raising a fun thing to
consider, which is digital assets and
ownership of those digital assets.
For now, we didn't have a technology that
could scale and that was good enough to
ensure that the digital assets that you
own were you yours and you had the
freedom of transaction on them.
I did understand that very fast and
because I'm a game player and as a game
player you always have your different
assets and do things with them.
And as well, I have been collecting music
and all kind of digital assets.
I bought this very famous collection of
punks and sold them very fast before I
could be a millionaire.
But due to in 2021 I decided that I
wanted to build something.
And then back then I went through this
beautiful project that was the first art
saw on Ethereum, which one of the artists
it was Daniel Friedman.
So I, as a curious person and person that
has been working with artists, I always
like to know what is the driver of those
artists, what they do, and try to get in
their walls, to understand better and to
get as much information as I can before I
decide to encourage or collect or just
always deeper on music or art.
For me, is very nice thing to do.
So I discovered these cards and education
was one of them.
And I went through Flickr which is where
it was the first at least that I found
place where it was.
And the license.
It was Creative Commons license of not
commercial use but it was an open license
which I been part of Creative Commons
community for a very long time since I
was working with musicians and I think it'
's one of the best things that happened
to the internet.
These are some of the pragmatic things
that the audience cares about.
Hopefully we will have some of these on
our games.
AI for sure is going to be there.
Free energy principle is going to be one
of the things that hopefully we help to
minimize and to make it funnier.
Games or happier games and games that
help organizations to be better.
The human factor, it's super important
for me.
And implementation and action I learned
by doing and it's one of the values that
the Institute encouraged more.
So I just jump on things and try to
understand them through doing and sharing
as I'm doing now.
Here are the epistemics and collective is
one of them that I'm as well.
Super interest agents, of course,
practical and curiosity which is the
adventure that I have the feeling that I'
'm being involved all my life and that I
encourage always my two girls to be
curious and to open things and look
behind the doors and just be an active.
Here are some values that I like to point
which are exploration, the culture of
curiosity that I did mention a lot.
Continuous learning because that
experience on the school.
I think I just keep going and keep going
and it's something that sometimes bad
experiences could turn out in good habits.
.
Learning by doing, as I already told.
Integrity and inclusivity.
Honesty, accountability, a big one.
Trying to be professional on everything
that you do.
For me, I started as human being.
Curious people of all backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome to the Institute.
.
I would be very happy to be the link and
to speak with someone that has doubts or
if I couldn't help.
I think I could help on the very early
stage.
If you're not very technical person, I
think I could help.
There we are learning by doing.
I would love to everyone that's on the
stream, I'm going to share this link
which is a new game that we are testing
and I'm excited to share it with you.
It's the adventure of Curiosity and here
Daniel.
I'm going to copy and paste the link.
It would be awesome.
Daniel: Okay.
There's a tiny typo on your slides.
It just ends with a curiosity.
Pablo: Thank you.
Daniel: But I'm going to paste it into
the YouTube live chat.
Pablo: Okay, thank you.
Yeah, I told you I'm a Dyslexic.
I have all kind of titles throughout my
life.
Sorry for that.
I always try to improve share the.
Daniel: Yeah, I put it in the YouTube
chat so people can head over there.
All right, yeah.
Could you tell us about this platform?
And this is the first active game?
Pablo: Yes, we started thinking on how to
do game a while ago and we decided to go
with this picture that explains how it
works.
Actually it's simple and you have four
pieces, the internal state, external
state, and in the middle you have the
sensory state and the active state.
So here is the mission.
You have some instructions that you can
read and would be fun if you go through
them and you can go either way.
And here we are going to go through the
sensory state where you're going to
listen to a music where some notes you
can censor that are not in the famous
song for Elise.
So you have to take notes and you can go
and you can see that we are on the Markov
blanket which saw everything very
delineate as Dali would paint it.
And here is your active part of the game
where you have to do something which is
add the different notes that your
professor, music professor is telling you
don't miss because you probably on the
external state are trying to play the
music.
So you have to infer that you are missing
some notes and go to the active state and
start walking through the right node.
If I miss the node, I just follow into
the nothing and come back into my
internal state.
So probably would have to go back and
sensor again.
And once I take the right actions and the
right nodes, I can go and solve the
puzzle.
And the idea here is to have a tool,
gaming tool to explain so you can
experience how this active inference on
free energy works.
And once you go to the end of that
adventure, which I'm not going to finish
because it's something that players
should do, you're going to have a door
where you have to put the sequence in low
case of what were the missing notes.
And it's going to allow you to come
inside the treasure room where you will
have feedback, feedback that you can send
us and we will be very happy to have it.
And then if you have a wallet, you will
be able to have digital asset.
If not, we will add information to help
people to go from web two to web three
and to get those digital assets.
And here to be developed would be future
adventures that I would be very happy to
do.
So this was pretty much the presentation
and hopefully we have new players in the
coming days.
Hope you have fun.
And I really encourage anyone to discover
and play with all these ideas and
thoughts and experiments and feelings
that I have the gut feeling that are
going to revolutionize how we understand
the world and how we can improve in it by
reducing uncertainty.
So thank you and I don't know, Daniel, if
you have any comments or something in
this last ten minutes.
Daniel: Oh, yeah, we can definitely talk
for a few minutes.
I'm seeing many fun comments and
questions in the chat so people can post
it.
Yeah, the gameplay is smoother on even a
normal computer.
It may look choppy on the live stream,
but it's quite a nice playing experience.
.
Maybe just a little context like how did
you get into building these worlds or
what kind of tools are these?
And we obviously don't see them in today'
's mainstream educational and research
offerings.
But what could that even be to bring
together this kind of immersion and role
playing with education research?
Pablo: Yes, I we playing role games and
role games you have very diverse kind of
players.
So I was playing with guys like me, had a
struggle through the school and guys that
end up being researchers like yourself
because they were very good in those
environments.
For me, it was like we are sharing a lot
of cognitive values and information and
they are really having fun with me.
So what the academia is telling me is not
what I'm feeling outside academia.
So that through the years it became more
and more clear that was one of the
drivers to have a very diverse kind of
friends and that one of the most
important things for me to learn.
It was having fun and to be a good
professional, I have to be enjoying what
I'm doing and to enjoy what I do, it has
to have that gamify feeling of it.
In 2021, I just went straight to explore
that road because Blockchains, what can
do is have a persistent sea of objects
and attributions to those objects and to
those wallets that you can add and build
on top of them.
It's like having a huge database for a
game purpose and then you figure out that
a game is kind of our organization.
So you need rules, you need to share
values, you need to have what we are
building now, which is the cecian cedo
which you agree with the players, what's
going to be about and how it's going to
work.
And we are building this fantastic
storytelling of how kind of world where
it was in the early 20s compared to what'
's happening now in this imaginary world
that's complementary to what's happening
in real life.
And we are just exploring those areas for
three years.
And once I got into the Institute, we
started serving these ideas.
You send us to do a system thinking
course that it was super cool.
We explore and learn and this document
that I can share, it was very important
for us to understand and we find out the
necessity to be able to compute what we
are doing.
So we start focusing more on ontology on
all the bricks that you need to
understand to build the skeleton of
something that could last for decades,
which is the idea.
And we are trying to build it so everyone
can copy, paste, fork it and do whatever
they want with the game, adapt it to
their own organizations and use it on
their favor.
And we are just exploring and having fun.
.
Daniel: That's awesome.
And there's so many pieces there.
It's true about the fun and the curiosity,
, those intrinsic motivations like being
6 hours deep into counting ants in the
desert or 5000 pipette pushes deep or
whatever it is in the trenches and in the
last mile.
And it can be easy to lose sight.
But when we lose sight and when we put
out the fire and the spark, it's a cold,
dark night, and no career or status or
extrinsic valuation is going to provide
simply the joy and the deeper meaning of
to two people going on a little adventure
running around this space, being inside
active inference rather than active
inference.
Being like this high speed train that's
leaving anyone behind or you're on the
outside and it's taking these twists and
turns and you're getting thrown off.
It's like it is cool and air conditioned
in this space and people play and watch a
lot of games where they wield violent
arms and not even like saying whether
that's good or bad.
It's just it is a genre to want to have a
camera either in a character's head first
person perspective or a camera in a
second or a third person perspective,
which you can switch between here and
those kinds.
Of topics about egocentric versus
allocentric navigation and our ability to
have a perspective swap on ourself and be
able to take that kind of like out of
body situational awareness in real
spatial settings and just to be able to
cruise through this space and it's like,
yeah, there's no right way to boomerang.
You could go from external to sensory.
You could go here or there.
It's an appetizer and a fertilization
that we've really just never seen.
Pablo: Okay, yeah.
Thank you very much, Daniel, for this.
Daniel: Any last thoughts or comments?
Pablo: No, just enjoy while we are here,
which is, I think, our mission.
All right.
Daniel: Thank you, Pablo.
I'm sure everyone's going to really enjoy
this and let's also, of course, continue
to develop these games and continue to
offer these on ramps and have times where
we're meeting up in these spaces and
playing around.
Pablo: Thank you.
All right, bye.
Daniel: Farewell.
Pablo: All right.
Daniel: Welcome, Mahault.
This will be the.